hello everyone and welcome back to the
russian uh
chess championship super final uh where
12 uh
fine gentlemen are fighting for the
title of the strongest uh gentleman in
russia we've already checked out one
game
from the women's section and now a game
by one of the leaders
of uh of the men's section yani ponchi
is leading the tournament
and out of the uh eight games he already
played he won four of them and drew
four of them and this is a game nine
whereas duboff
did lose a lose one game to maxim chi
guyv uh
in the second round of the tournament
but this game it's very very uh
very very interesting as you will very
rarely see
uh when for example nepo is playing or
when dubo is playing that it will be a
boring game when two of them are playing
together
uh we can expect a very very interesting
game uh so without further ado let's
check it out
dooba with the white pieces opens with
d4
uh we have knight to f6 by nippo c4 g6
and
knight to c3 we go into the king's
indian defense and now
d5 uh transposing into the groomfeld
c captures knight captures and now e4 so
just the
the mean line of the grunfeld knight
captures on c3b captures and bishop to
g7
and now there are a couple of moves how
white can continue
uh in this position bishop to c4 being
by far the most popular however
duboff goes bishop to b5 with check and
now asks nipple what do you play here so
nipple blocks with the pawn forces the
bishop to move
bishop to a4 and b5 now we have bishop
back to b3
and now a5 by nepo the the most played
move
is b4 here you want to weaken the center
and
make well make this bishop even more
powerful but okay
nepo goes a5 and now knight to f3
and here both players castle castles
castles and now
uh there is one game from 1997 in a game
between viktor korsner and alexander
finkel
uh where c5 was played and uh victor was
able to win that game however here we
have a4
and it's as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game
so bishop must retreat bishop back to c2
and then now comes c5 now striking in
the center
nepal wants to make this bishop uh uh
well even more powerful so rook to b1
do both moves it and now knight to c6
continuing to put pressure
on the center here and now finally d5
grabbing more space in the center
knights to e5 and we have a trade once
captures captures and then now comes
bishop h6 attacking the rook here
and now while you can move the rook or
retreat the bishop it's not
all that impressive because for example
after captures captures
uh this b5 pawn is very weak here you
cannot capture it right away because of
bishop to a6 but after something like
bishop uh d3 or even just rook to e1
getting
the rook out of harms away it's going to
be very hard for
black to play this you're going to have
to play something like c4 and this is
just a very very ugly this is a
constant weakness and once white picks
this pawn up and
white will do that it's just going to be
uh well
a very difficult position for black to
play so here nepo decides to play in
great style he plays
bishop to a6 he bishop to a6 he offers
the rook on f8
uh and dubof captures it with bishop
captures king captures now and now comes
f4 c4 is also very interesting as this
is a target
and well you might want to play c4 to
mess up
black's beautiful pawn structure on the
king side also this will weaken the a4
pawn
uh but okay duba goes f4 first puts
pressure on the bishop and now
uh nepo just captures it we have bishop
captures and not
rook to f3 so giving a little bit of
material
back uh to gain some uh initiative going
and here
uh although bishop to d4 is a perfectly
reasonable move just getting the bishop
out of harm's way
with tempo uh nipple goes queen to a5
and queen to a5 although it does
serve a service purpose defends the
bishop and c3 also adds more protection
to the b5 pawn
uh it does bring the queen away from all
the action
and well if you uh look at black's
king's side
it does seem plausible that all the
action will happen on the king's side
so here dubai continues pushing in the
center we have e5
and now uh what do you play here best
for black would be bishop to d for
check move the king and then bishop back
to b7
and now everything is nicely defended
this pawn is under attack but but after
bishop to e4
it's very hard uh to this uh to decide
how to continue playing this game
with black this pawn is very weak you
can't really uh you can't really
defend it other than maybe just leaving
the queen there but you know f5 is
coming and the black's position will
just fall apart slowly
so instead after e5 nep played king to
g8 now getting the king away from the f
file so
these moves can be met with just
captures
but this doesn't really work e6 now is
possible right away but uh dugo first
wants to
get his king to a safer square king h1
and now
rook to d8 going after the pawn here and
now comes e6 and e6 looks a bit weird
because
if you capture you cannot recapture but
this is exactly what the duo wanted
f captures on e6 and now uh feel free to
pause the video here and try to figure
out what do both had in mind
while i give you a couple of seconds
also might might use this as a thumbnail
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
spotting the beautiful bishop sacrifice
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's bishop captures and g6 and now uh
you don't really have all that much to
try here it's either
capture the bishop or play something
else but nothing comes to mind for
example if you try something like rook
captures on d5 with an attack on the
queen
white will persist with the bishop
sacrifice bishop captures an h7
with check king captures and now queen
to e2 for example
and the the king being here it's just
too ugly rook can come to h3
queen can come to g4 it's just going to
be a very quick checkmate
or even if you try defending let's say
bishop g7 just queen captures on e6
attacks the rook now you defend the rook
and defend from any future checks
rook g3 now threatening check followed
by checkmate
and once you stop that because the rook
now covers the sixth rank just queen f7
and there's just no defense against this
queen c3 is covered by the rook
and this game over uh black can play a
few more useless moves but that's pretty
pretty pointless so after this bishop
captures on g6
nepo decided to capture the bishop and
now comes queen to c2 and this is the
only good move here
if you try something like rook g3 then
rook captures uh on d5
is coming and you won't have a lot of
fun because uh
well it's just an
unnecessary move to allow so first queen
to c2
now threatening g6 bishop back to g7
uh blocking any any checks and now comes
rook to g3 queen captures in g6 is
possible but then again you allow uh
black to to recollect his forces however
after rook to g3
there's just not all that much you can
play here
g5 was played uh trying to get some
get some pawns in front of the white
king you know in between the the rook
and the king
however here we have queen to g6 again
rook captures on g5 now allows again
rook captures on d5 and you don't have
time for queen g6 because then
rook captures rook and you don't have
enough pieces to finish the
game here so after g5 we have queen to
g6
and now comes queen back to d2 uh now
rook captures on d5
isn't all that great queen captures with
check uh just picks up the rook
so instead after queen to g6 we have
queen to d2
but again it's not a lot the queen is
basically waiting for for the rook to
move so the queen can occupy the c3
square and uh
defend the bishop here but it's it's
very passive but it's
it's the only thing nipple can do here
so rook captures on g5
and now queen to c3 defending the bishop
and now queen captures on e6 with
check it's very hard for for black to
even find moves here king to f8 and now
rook to e1 putting pressure on this pawn
threatening to capture it
so uh here you could try something like
rook d7 to defend it but then d6 is just
ugly if this then it's
checkmate and if of course row captures
then you can just capture on e7
so here nepal tries one last idea queen
capture sunny one with
check but now comes uh just queen
capture sunny one
uh so giving up the queen uh sorry uh
queen captures on e1
and then now comes the queen captures on
e1 and now
bishop to f6 defending uh and here uh
instead of moving the rook just queen to
h4 point is that if the
uh rook is captured just queen h8 check
and you lose the the rook here
so after this uh we have rook to d6 uh
just
defending uh and uh removing the rook
from the back rank
and now queen to h7 again if you allow
this bishop captures then just have
captures and
the pawn can be promoted all the way so
after
queen h7 with king the e8 and now comes
queen g8
check king to d7 and now even queen the
a8
so what do you do here bishop captures
and g5 was played
f captures on g5 and now c4 so it's a
bishop and rook against the queen
with black having a very advanced past c
pawn uh however uh white doesn't care
it's a very
it's very easy to stop that pawn with b4
and now
queen the a7 with check we have king to
e8 and now
queen to b8 with check connecting with
the pawn
king f7 and now queen captures on b4
uh we have rook captures on d5 and now
just queen captures on a4
and uh it was in this position that uh
yanni formula should resign the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the bishop is under attack
if you move it away from the c pawn then
just queen captures that's uh
not possible so after something like
bishop b5 with c queen
c2 going after the h7 square but after
king g7
just queen to e4 attacking both the rook
and the pawn and of course
after the rook defends the pawn just h5
and it's uh
it's a game over so after
queen captures on a4 uh a brilliant
victory by dubois
and uh well it's uh very interesting to
see what will happen uh in the
championship
and while i'm recording this the final
round is being played and
uh well uh yanni pony she drew his last
game
and it's up to sergey karakin who is
trying to catch up to him to
uh to see if he if uh kara king will
maybe win the championship
or if kara can draws his game it will be
a tie and then he will have to
go into playoffs against dianne ponnishi
uh the problem is karakin is playing
against the dubo and it's such a crazy
game that
it's most likely the next game we're
going to show after this one
so stay tuned uh the that game is uh
coming very very shortly uh so
that's the game i do hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said uh when either of
them are playing it's a great game when
two of them are playing together it's
gonna get you know fireworks will happen
so
i really hope you enjoyed this one uh so
yeah i would like to thank uh samuel
cathage alessandro
papa uh paglialunga uh kevin fetterly
uh david grosskind and joseph posanski
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the russian
championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
and of course after we finish
all that is happening uh we return to
the to the morphe
saga uh thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day